hey everyone with the recent expansion
of web 3.0 the rapid growth in the
fields of artificial intelligence and
Quantum Computing and the announcement
of the implementation of ethereum merge
in 2023 the tech world is expected to
grow massively in the current economy
Tech organizations are driven by highly
skilled I.T Personnel thus offering
lucrative positions to support the
growing digital economy
organizations of false Isis are willing
to pay a hefty sum to those capable of
Bridging the rising Tech skill Empire
with their further education
certifications and work experience
hey everyone you are already watching
simply learn and here we are with the
list of the top 10 highest paying jobs
for 2023. if you love watching videos
like this do hit the Subscribe button to
never miss any updates from Simply
learning so let's explore and learn
about them one by one starting with the
10th position which is full stack
developer every business needs a website
in this day and age and the demand for
full stack developers is growing more
than ever a full stack developer works
on a web applications front end which
includes the website's layout and the
back end deals with the website's
functionality like a database
for example how the information in your
website is laid out in browsers and on
mobile devices as well skills required
for becoming a full stack developer are
front-end languages and Frameworks like
HTML and CSS back-end Technologies and
Frameworks like JavaScript and its
environments like node.js and express.js
database Management Systems Version
Control
now talking about the salary the average
salary of a full stack developer is a
hundred thousand one hundred one dollars
in the US and 6 lakh rupees in India
at the ninth position we have Android
developer an Android developer designs
applications and software specifically
for Android devices and the Google Play
Store Apple iOS and Microsoft's Windows
iPhone platforms among other mobile
platforms
here are some skills you'll need to get
started in Android development on your
own
knowledge of the principles of secure
and Reliable Software designs exposure
to and comprehension of some development
methodologies such as agile scrum and
others as well as development
environments programming expertise in
two or more languages especially popular
ones like SQL Java JavaScript c-sharp or
C plus plus python PHP Ruby on Rails the
salary of an Android developer in the US
is 102 744 dollars and up to 5.2 lakh
rupees in India following that at the
eighth position we have big data
engineer big data is characterized by
its amount variability and velocity of
data hence having a professional to
handle it is essential the fact that
there will always be data means that
there are many prospects for Big Data
Engineers a big data engineer is a
specialist twist in charge of creating
maintaining testing analyzing and
assessing a company's data Big Data
refers to extraordinary huge data sets
here are the skills required to become a
big data engineer comprehensive
understanding of Hadoop spark and
related Frameworks scripting language
expertise including Java C plus Linux
Ruby PHP Python and R understanding of
redis and mongodb among other nosql and
rdbms databases knowledge of the tools
for mesos AWS and Docker ability to
solve complex networking data and
software issues now coming to the salary
the average salary of a big data
engineer is 109 650 US Dollars and 7.8
lakh rupees in India
next up at the seventh position is AWS
developer with Amazon generating 10.8
million dollars in Revenue in just the
second quarter of 2022 Amazon web
services AWS is currently one of the
most popular cloud service providers on
the market this expansion indicates that
demand for positions such as those of
AWS developers is still Rising AWS
developers work with applications or
programs on the cloud-based Amazon web
services platform their main job is to
make an organization's use of AWS
Services which encompasses everything
from content distribution and code
authoring to data storage as efficient
as possible now to talk about the skills
experience working with core AWS
features and services experience with
cloud-based Monitoring Solutions a solid
understanding of cloud security tools
experience with maintaining or building
applications in the cloud
now the average salary of an AWS
developer is 109 600 in us and 6.5 lakh
rupees in India
following that in the sixth position is
robotics engineer robotics engineering
is a developing field that combines
engineering computer science and data
analysis robotics engineer come up with
Innovative robots designed Concepts and
build prototypes to fine-tune the
robot's details they create designs and
collaborate with groups of other
engineers and designers
now skills robotics engineer do needs
are building configuring and testing
robots designing software systems to
control the robotic systems such as
those robots used for manufacturing
analyzing and evaluating the prototypes
and robotic systems they have created
this is generally a never-ending task
since technology is constantly changing
and advancing reviewing and approving
cost estimates and design calculations
now the average salary of a robotics
engineer is 98 534 US Dollars and five
lakh rupees in India then at the fifth
position is devops engineer implementing
devops frequently necessitates an
organizational redesign in organizations
where development and operations are
handled independently to properly adopt
devops you need the right people culture
and devops engineers
the goal of a devops engineer is to
balance needs through the whole software
development life cycle from coding and
deployment to maintenance and updates
skills required to acquire to become a
devops engineer include prior work
history as a 24 7 cloud or SAS operation
team member knowledge of infrastructure
management and surveillance
strong acquaintance with devops platform
tools Chef puppet and Docker working
understanding of middleware
configuration and automation service
provisioning the ability for both
Independents and teamwork powerful
analytical abilities
now talking about the salary ranges
between 110 821 US Dollars and in India
the average salary is 7.5 lakh rupees
then at the fourth position is software
engineer
software Engineers also called software
developers design and create softwares
for computers and applications you might
find a career as a software engineer
fulfilling if you're an analytical
thinker who appreciates problem solving
and making digital things easier to use
now the skills required for a software
engineer are designing and maintaining
software systems evaluating and testing
new software programs optimizing
software for Speed and scalability
writing and testing code Consulting with
clients Engineers security Specialists
and other stakeholders
now the average salary of a software
engineer in the US is 113 775 US Dollars
and in India it's 6.5 lakh rupees
and the third position is blockchain
developer according to research the
market for blockchain technology will
grow at a cagr of 85.9 percent from 2020
to 2030. it makes sense that blockchain
would be among the vocations with the
highest demand in 2023. blockchain
developers basically create systems to
collect and preserve blockchain data in
a way that hinders alterations or
hackers enabling secure digital
transactions now talking about the
skills required to become a blockchain
developer is good knowledge of
programming languages like Java Python
and C plus knowledge of algorithms data
structure and back-end development
understanding blockchain Technologies
and cryptography thorough understanding
of blockchain management best practices
and data security and the salary of a
blockchain developer is 108 539 US
Dollars and 7.5 lakh rupees in India
then at the second position is machine
learning engineer LinkedIn claims that
between 2021 and 2022 recruiting for
machine learning Engineers increased by
32 percent
the need for machine learning experts is
skyrocketing as more firms look into
using them to safeguard their operations
against upcoming challenges
This Way Machine learning Engineers have
received the second best job in the 2023
ranking
now talking about the skills these are
the skills required to become a machine
learning engineer
statistics and probability data modeling
programming languages like python C plus
artificial intelligence algorithms
coming to the salary the average salary
of a machine learning engineer is 136
415 dollars in the US and nine lakh
rupees in India and at the topmost
position we have is data scientists to
gain a thorough picture of how a company
operates the data scientist's job
description calls for gathering
information from multiple sources and
analyzing it the data scientist creates
intelligent responses to business
difficulties by automating particular
organizational procedures using
statistical and analytical techniques
and AI tools
here are the skills required for a data
scientist making estimates for
additional analysis using statistical
techniques is made possible by
probability and technical skills like
machine learning deep learning
processing large data sets data
visualization data wrangling mathematics
and programming now talking about the
salary then the average salary of a data
scientist in the US is 121 417 dollars
and in India it's 11 lakh rupees
so with that we come to the end of this
list although these are 10 of the
highest paying jobs in technology many
other fields like cyber security and
digital marketing are short on skilled
professionals so keep looking if any of
those careers described above or
mentioned now interest you before I sign
off make sure you subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update we'll be back with more
such interesting videos until then keep
learning and stay tuned on simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here